le grand scientifique stefano king
complètement paralysé depuis 40 ans
viennent vivre une expérience unique
volet en apesanteur un vieux rêve qui a
un but
le scientifique anglais comptent bien
aller dans l'espace car pour lui c'est
l'avenir
patrick esther l'ivresse de la liberté
absolue
son intelligence fait de lui le meilleur
physicien mondial depuis einstein les
depuis 40 ans son corps lui échappe
atteint par une maladie dégénérative
hier soir grâce un boeing 727 effectuant
des trajectoire parabolique stephen
hawking a pu s'affranchir de son
fauteuil roulant et apprécier la
pesanteur quatre petites minutes au
total
mais avec chaque fois le sentiment d'
atteindre le ciel est de toucher le
paradis avant le décollage
l'homme qui ne communiquent que grâce à
un ordinateur à synthèse vocale commandé
par des contractions delajoux avait
expliqué sa démarche
beaucoup de gens m'ont demandé pourquoi
je voulais faire ce vol pour de
nombreuses raisons mais principalement
parce que je crois que la vie sur terre
risque d'être balayés un jour par un
désastre comme le réchauffement global
de température ou une guerre nucléaire
ou encore par un virus modifiés
génétiquement
je pense que l'espèce humaine n'a pas de
futur si elle ne va pas dans l'espace
dans deux ans à bord de cet engin
spatial stéphane espère bien renouveler
l'expérience se faire partie du premier
vol commercial monté par richard bronson
avec la compagnie virgin galactic
la première société à offrir des
possibilités de voyage spatial deux
heures de vol dont six minutes en
apesanteur un ticket d'un million
d'euros mais probablement offert à
stefano king
[Musique]